[Music]
how is this for a birthday present it's
not bad i mean it's not bad now a little
bird told me that you might have spent
the morning washing your car i did how
did you know that i mean a car washes
and toilets when you have two kids
that's the only time you're after
yourself
okay listen the birthday was yesterday
we got the emmy tonight what's the turn
up like tonight i know we're all staying
in the same hotel so
am i getting like the turnip will be
real
holding a well-deserved drink the
birthday boy hit the ted lasso
after-party at sunset tower the cast
celebrating four big wins including one
for hannah waddingham who won for
supporting actress in a comedy series
what's the night brain
[Music]
baby girl
[Music]
yeah she's pretty you said you're gonna
put her in your daughter's room is that
true
yes yeah my little seven-year-old
sausage face i'm gonna put it in her
room because i want her to know that i
don't ever go away from her lightly i'm
a single mom and i need her to know that
i've got a damn good reason for going
and i'll always scuttle back
kev snapped this red carpet pic of
hannah with fellow emmy winner co-star
and the internet's new boyfriend brett
goldstein look at these two holding
hands walking down the carpet
[Music]
will you do the roy kent cheer tonight
[Applause]
ted lasso
it's become a phenomenon we just never
thought it would be like this so we're
just very grateful
and emmys weren't the only things
birthday boy jason walked away with
remember his golden globes acceptance
speech and a hoodie in case you feel
like going back to your roots and a
medium always a compliment always you
know
they run big they run big but they also
run very soft so it's very nice
during jason's acceptance speech he made
sure to shout out former snl boss lorne
michaels but not in a way anyone
expected i want to thank lauren who went
to go take a dump now
perfect
lauren came by here too and we told him
that you mentioned he was in the
bathroom
yeah how'd that go that didn't go so
well not so well you know one's not
ready for prime time player always not
ready for prime time player it's all
love because in the press room lauren
hinted jason could host this upcoming
season which premieres october 2nd i was
so happy for jason and uh he'll be
coming back soon tess and l so i'm very
happy about that as well but there's
still no official word on which cast
members will return lots of speculation
will you be back what are we it's still
we're still figuring it out i'm thinking
it will probably
happen but it's still you know nothing's
for sure ellen pompeo who presented the
governor's award to debbie allen is
gearing up to scrub in for grey's
anatomy season 18 premieres next
thursday and she sure made it sound like
she's ready to move on i've been trying
to get away for years
i have strong relationships at the
network and they have been very very
good to me
and incentivized me to stay dr addison
montgomery is coming back to grace lowe
memorial hospital kate walsh is
returning correct yes that's one of my
favorite things about the show right now
is having
original cast members come back yeah
it's so fun and so nostalgic it will be
the final season of this is us new mom
mandy moore has all the feelings now
that they're back on set we just started
work on the final season about a week
ago it's it's already tears this family
is disbanding i wonder what he would do
right now
we're gonna tie all of these uh these
mysteries so that you can leave this
show satisfied another beloved show
ending this season blackish last night
was anthony anderson's 11th emmy loss
which could have been a good thing after
kevin's red carpet bet if anthony
anderson wins the night i will rip off
this tux and run down the carpet in my
draws
i'll be that hype i'm i'ma do it with
you
i'ma do it with you anthony says if he
wins we're gonna do a special run down
the red carpet afterwards will you join
us oh i could do it in my birkenstocks
well we're gonna be in our underwear i
will not join you for that but i thank
you for warning me in advance
meanwhile some real-life couples had
more emmy reveals like juan division
nominee paul bettany with his wife
jennifer connolly
i'm happy to be here with him and
celebrating his work
will there be a season two i'm already
in if it's if it's there i'm in
it's great to be here
bradley whitford had fan girl wife amy
landecker filming him as we got the
nominee and his cast talking handmaid's
tale we're new for season five already
what does that mean uh that means uh
daddy's got a job came with your wife
tonight right yeah come on
this is a date night for us we just had
a baby we had a good night's sleep thank
you thank god for making
meanwhile some real-life couples had
more emmy reveals like juan division
nominee paul bettany with his wife
jennifer connolly
i'm happy to be here with him and
celebrating his work
will there be a season two i'm already
in if it's if it's there i'm in
it's great to be here bradley whitford
had fan girl wife amy landecker filming
him as we got the nominee and his cast
talking handmaid's tale we're new for
season five already what does that mean
uh that means uh daddy's got a job and
what's your wife tonight right yeah come
on
this is a date night for us we just had
a baby we had a good night's sleep thank
you thank god for making
can we take a moment please you're
married to her thank you i know
sometimes i look at these events and i
can't believe my luck
catherine zeta jones was dripping in
diamonds and dropping not so subtle
hints to hubby michael douglas they're
just beautiful lorraine schwartz she
really knows how to do it and um
hey guys i got a birthday coming up
rapping presenter rita wilson didn't
seem to want to explain why her nominee
hubby skipped the show did tom already
go in did he go in or do you leave him
because he's taking too long to get
ready it's your wife or girlfriend my
wife's at home with the you know
more solo stars nominee reggae jean-page
without girlfriend emily brown and
presenter kaylee cuoco making her first
appearance since announcing her divorce
meanwhile presenter kerry washington
only posed alone hyping up her hubby's
movie i think the star of sylvie's love
is here is he here the star i heard he
was here i'm going to say hey that's it
we both have shows premiering this week
how do we take him down vanessa lachey
was all in on tonight's debut of ncis
hawaii nick meanwhile is premiering
alter ego wednesday on fox then they
both have season two of love is blind
welcome everyone
it is come on
and it's um it's coming out february of
2022 and
i don't know am i allowed to say we shot
season three already
she just did
kate winslet
yes i am the winner what's the party
like tonight ned my husband wants
tequila he keeps saying oh we need to
kill a winner tequila it's tequila ned
naked
that's his brothers call him nitro and
the naked part you just have to kind of
figure that out okay come on up here
don't put him on tv
[Laughter]
oh my god that would be hilarious
kate's mayor of east town co-stars
julianne nicholson and evan peters also
took home hardware i felt like i was
going to throw up you realize that you
screamed okay kate winslet
no
no did i do that
the hbo drama earned a total of four
trophies but lost out on the coveted
outstanding limited series title that
honor went to anya taylor joyce the
queen's gambit
the queen's gambit
so what are we doing tonight how are we
partying tonight how are you so we're
getting ready to go tonight we're gonna
play games we're gonna go play games
nice
yeah i think jess is the only thing
we're not playing tonight actually but
perhaps the most emotional moment of the
night jean smart's lead actress in a
comedy win for hax the legendary star
who walked the red carpet with her
thirteen-year-old son forest thanked her
late husband and designing women co-star
richard gilliland who
passed away six months yesterday i would
not be here
without him we were all so moved by your
speech
and
i'm so sorry for your loss what would
your husband say to you if uh if you
were here now oh gosh well he'd be very
happy for me i i was i was thrilled to
share it with my youngest
and uh he's ecstatic
and first i have to go to work at the
crack of dawn tomorrow
so i have to can't party too much
tonight